Court is in session
plaintiff mr. Cohen is suing his current
roommate mr. Hubert for only showering
once a week and using a self prepared
slurry of avocado oatmeal and egg whites
in place of commercial shampoo
all right gentlemen why are you here
before me today my roommate mr. Huber is
on like this vegan all-natural kick and
as such he has foregone all basic
hygiene like shampoo soap toothpaste
smells like garbage I mean you're not
supposed to shower you know every day of
the week so I have developed my own
concoction that is all-natural with with
no chemicals and your objection with it
is what it smells bad it's making he
sells you smells like the last day of
burning sir you come before the court
but what damages are you looking for
here I'm looking for six hundred and
fifty dollars in reimbursements for
groceries and no more outbursts every
day how did you arrive at that figure
yeah good I mostly just multiplied by
two or three the amount of groceries
that I bought so that's the amount of
avocados pro rata amortize the
arbitration and tries the arbitration of
the pro rata over the course and they
appreciate the FICA sure yeah that makes
sense
how am I supposed to know if we both buy
avocados how am I supposed to know that
I'm using his avocados I mean we're
they're all in one basket yeah I have a
couple questions by the avocados yeah
hard or soft soft I get in whenever
they're the ripe stickers on a big dress
or long thick girth we're talking dirty
very dirty very girthy yeah there's a
little seed very girthy I understood
tell me again what with the other
elements that this were so it's half an
avocado half a tablespoon of coconut oil
which I melt down I process some oatmeal
put that in there and then I also use
one egg and in some he he only eats egg
whites so it pleases the court and does
I would like the defendant to please
step forward and see me in chambers
it's disgusting it's gonna make the even
return that's what I deal with every day
understood every day
he smells like leftover Denny's I have
brought Exhibit A oh wow I got all the
exhibit I'm willing to get sir
if you stink you are not dank that's
what they say
I watched the People vs OJ Simpson this
me too it's amazing
dude it's good yeah it really is John
Travolta he's like doing a thing it's a
screen it doesn't move it's always
amazing yeah really good um how long is
this conflict been brewing I've been
doing this vegan all-natural organic
shampoo for six months if it bothers mr.
Cohen so much why can't you just use
shampoo I used a shampoo face wash body
wash one time and it made me breaking
out into hives so I haven't trusted it
since I'm trying to get a picture of
what the conflict is really like beyond
the terrible smell so just that if we
can solve that then we can bring
priority that you felt this way about me
I tell him every day mm-hmm nothing
further that you would like to the court
to know before I render a decision that
I don't use my product on animals so I
mean I'm doing good stuff here we have
animals at home like in his head we're
sure I mean there's animals everywhere I
mean I but do you have animals anywhere
no well then isn't it just ingenuously
to come before this court and claim that
you do not test on animals that you just
admitted you don't have anywhere
yes thank you you know I
the court is reminded of Joseph Stalin
who said of course you can't make an
omelet without breaking some eggs
thankfully perchance you can have good
make a fragrance set without breaking
somebody else's eggs no you definitely
can you can use shampoo we've heard
enough the court will now render a
verdict after a moment of deliberation
court hereby finds in favor of that guy
thank you that's today's business
everyone dismissed